la roumanie bouge en plein mais la
répression semble terrible on parle de
plusieurs centaines de morts au pays
ceausescu neuf morts 13 blessés lourd
bilan de la tempête ce week-end en
france le calme est revenu mais le vent
menace à nouveau dernier hommage au fils
prodigue c'était les funérailles
d'andrei sakharov
moscou a exprimé ces derniers regrettent
de plus en plus beau de plus en plus
cher le tunnel sous la manche va des
records 70 milliards de francs au lieu
de 50
bonsoir quand même malgré ces petits
incidents de caméras il y avait quatre
titres je vous en ai donné quatre comme
prévu la roumanie d'abord alors que tous
les autres pays de l'est bouger se
libérer rejeté l'oppression la roumanie
paraissait paralysé par la toute
puissance des chaussées ce coup c'est
fini depuis samedi des heurts violents
ont opposé plusieurs milliers de
manifestants hostiles au dictateur les
ont opposés à la police et à l'armée
c'était un arabe et à timur soir près de
la frontière hongroise
des estimations très contradictoires
circulent sur le nombre des victimes
certains parlent d'un ou deux morts
seulement d'autres d'un véritable
massacre
plusieurs centaines de tués pour
l'instant il est impossible d'avoir la
moindre confirmation
jérôme baugnies j'ai peur explique le
pasteur là ces autos pêche dans cet
appel au secours diffusé il ya quinze
jours par la télévision hongroise
ils ont essayé de m'assassiner ils
cassent chaque nuit nos carreaux et ceux
de l'église nous sommes barricadés dans
notre maison des amis dorment avec nous
car c'est insupportable
nous avons envoyé notre fils chez ses
grands parents mais j'ai peur pour ma
famille c'est pour défendre ce pasteur
et son épouse que toute la population
s'est opposé à la police qui voulait les
déportés leur chaîne humaine a tourné à
l'émeute antigouvernementale la plus
grave depuis deux ans cela s'est passé
ici même un timisoara près de la
frontière hongroise par des témoins ont
été sanglants et les versions divergent
fortement concernant les mort éventuelle
un témoin oculaire contacté directement
par téléphone à timisoara affirmé qu'il
avait écrasé par un char et de
progresser avec seveso roumain
en exil à berlin williams pottok a quant
à lui affirmé en citant des témoins sur
place les forces de l'ordre avaient
ouvert le feu à la mitraillette sur les
manifestants nous réduirons praille 400
personnes pourtant nicolas ceaucescu n'a
pas annulé sa visite officielle à
téhéran où il a été reçu cet après midi
par le président rafsandjani mise au ban
de la société internationale le compte
du quator veut ainsi montrer qu'il lui
reste un minimum d'audience à budapest
la foule hongroise manifesté ce soir
avec tous les réfugiés de transylvanie
devant l'ambassade de bucarest
toutes les frontières romaines viennent
d'être bouclés le pays se referme sur la
répression tout à l'heure à paris devant
l'ambassade de roumanie une
manifestation a rassemblé plusieurs
centaines de personnes essentiellement
des roumains vivant en france qui
demandait à la communauté internationale
de les aider à contrer la dictature de
ceausescu
et puis sachez que demain matin demain
matin l'invité des 4 vérités de
télématin de françois ponchaud les à
7h45 ce sera l'ex roi michel de roumanie
en exil depuis 47 il appelle au
rassemblement du peuple
boum ça a soufflé ça souffle encore mais
ça va souffler encore plus s'il s'agit
bien sûr de la tempête qui a régné toute
la france ce week-end après le temps
exceptionnellement beau et calme qui a
régné durant ces derniers mois
les conditions météo ont changé
brusquement quelques jours le temps est
doux mais ça décoiffe sans compter que
la tempête a fait aussi des victimes
neuf morts et 13 blessés
stéphane magnier rappel voici ce qui se
passe parfois à bord d'un porte
containers lorsque la mer se déchaîne
celui-ci est espagnol il s'appelle rudy
haddad marc le gouvernail c'est d'abord
bloqué puis la cargaison s'est
désarrimée les énormes caisson ont été
ballottés comme de vulgaire fétu de
paille écrasant tout sur leur passage
les 21 hommes d'équipage en seront
quittes pour la peur et seront remorqué
jusqu en rade de brest
d'ailleurs en début d'après midi ces
images tournées devant la rochelle
symboliser bien la situation générale la
mer est encore forte mais elle s'appelle
laissant derrière elle son cortège de
dégâts et de bilan catastrophique
ici les vagues oranges et plusieurs
mètres de route sapant à la base une
dizaine de bâtiments ailleurs comme dans
cette rue de lille
c'est une maison des vieux quartiers qui
ces fonds au total la tempête aura fait
neuf morts ou disparus en france 13
blessés graves et des dégâts qu'il
faudra plusieurs jours pour estimer
l'image forte et tragique de ce week-end
restera cette séquence filmée par notre
confrère de fr3 brest je pique de large
il voulait faire encore mieux il sera
emporté par une vague
quelques instants plus tard
et la grande bretagne a payé un tribut
encore plus lourd 13 morts ce petit port
de porter les veines en cornouailles a
été en grande partie submergé par les
flots
au large on reste et ce soir encore sans
nouvelles de 15 marins espagnols
impliqués dans de nos phrases et la
météo annoncée ou un possible retour
mauvais temps pour mes recrues
pour l'heure le vent c'est un petit peu
calmé mais il faut rester très prudent
car les prévisions météo ne sont pas
optimistes normalement une autre tempête
est annoncée
laurent cabrol vous confirmez laurent
hervé nous allons en fait échanger une
tempête contre un coup de vent ce qui
sera un moindre mal que s'est-il passé
durant ce congé de fin de semaine voici
cette carte qui nous l'expliquent une
dépression très creuse 960 millibars
octobre pascal si vous avez un baromètre
vous avez pu le constater parfois même
cette dépression engendré ces vents très
violents que nous avons connue mais elle
s'en va elle s'est échappée vers les
pays scandinaves et aujourd'hui eh bien
nous avons eu une sorte de permutations
regardez cette seconde carte
elles apparaissent sur votre écran la
dépression qui engendrait la tempête
elle est partie celle qui nous intéresse
la voici 980 millibars hectopascals un
petit peu moins puissantes moins
virulente et donc les vents seront moins
fort ses vents seront sensibles
également sur l' atlantique et sur la
manche dans la soirée de demain mardi et
dans la matinée de mercredi mais des
vents beaucoup moins violent 100 120
kilomètres heure en rafales
attention tout de même et à l'intérieur
des terres 80 kilomètres par heure sur
la moitié nord du pays
voilà d'autres précisions tout à l'heure
à la fin du journal a tout de suite
leurs tempêtes au parti socialiste aussi
mais sous les crânes cette fois les
socialistes sont réveillés ce week end à
la proche du congrès de rennes qui se
tiendra en mars prochain et c'est pierre
moreau l'actuel secrétaire qui en a fait
les frais il a été très attaqué
notamment par monsieur chevènement et de
l'or cet après midi à lille pierre
mauroy tenait une conférence de presse
pas de règlements de compte et pas de
petites phrases at il dit et il a pris
l'initiative d'écrire aux militants pour
rappeler à la synthèse jean-michel
mercurol jean roland sicard au parti
socialiste la préparation du congrès se
fait à couteaux tirés
bien sûr les grands chefs du parti tente
de garder le sourire affirme vouloir en
rester aux débats d'idées
un débat qui semble pourtant tourné à la
guerre psychologique anti mauroy à grand
renfort de motions et d' attaque
personnelle exemple ce week-end
pierre joxe propose une direction
collégiale jean pierre chevènement sort
l'artillerie lourde et parle de maladies
infantiles du socialisme jack lang
distille des compliments en forme
d'éloge funèbre et jacques delors pour
le clan mermaz tire à vue sur la gestion
mort depuis que lionel jospin n'est plus
premier secrétaire
le parti socialiste n'existe pas à
l'extérieur
pierre mauroy a senti le danger le
premier secrétaire a entendu siffler les
balles autour de sa tête
résultat un repli stratégique et
médiatique sur sa fédération du nord et
une contre attaque tous azimuts ces
petites phrases il y en a de tous des
saints elles sont tantôt irresponsable
tantôt assassine souvent médiocre et
toujours nuisible pour le parti
socialiste
j'observe que le parti est agressée
certains lui reprochent des divisions
qui sont créés par ceux là même qui les
dénoncent je ne participe d'aucune
manière
à ce petit jeu un petit jeu auquel un
seul des grands chefs du parti n'a pas
encore vraiment pris par lionel jospin
en rivalité avec laurent fabius reste
discret affirme seulement vouloir
soutenir pierre mauroy sa voix pourrait
bien faire la différence si la guerre de
succession
un jour et est officiellement déclarée
au parti communiste les reconstructeurs
ne sont pas satisfaits des résultats du
comité central les contestataires du
parti juste en particulier que la
position de la direction du pc sur les
pays de l'est n'est pas acceptable
ce sont l'ordre la faire des fausses
factures de nancy 2 sommes importantes
été placé en garde à vue ce matin
bernard fois ses vice présidents de la
chambre de commerce et d'industrie de
meurthe et moselle et son secrétaire
général gérard bouthier et à l'instant
même
nous avons appris que monsieur x c'est
avait été inculpé et écroué
isabelle bechler explications
les inculpations comme s'il en pleuvait
le 25e ou 26e protagonistes selon les
décomptes de l' affaire dite des fausses
factures de nancy vient de passer une
heure et demie dans le cabinet
d'instruction du juge t-il bernard fois
c'est vice président de la chambre de
commerce et d'industrie de
meurthe-et-moselle propriétaire de
plusieurs grandes surfaces d'ameublement
a écouté le juge t-il lui notifier son
inculpation recel d'abus de biens
sociaux corruption active et passive il
sera écroué dès ce soir à épinal bernard
fois c'est était membre depuis plusieurs
années de la cdc du département de cette
instance qui attribue les autorisations
d'implantation de grandes surfaces
tout comme le député maire de toul
jacques gosso qui est écroué depuis
vendredi dernier
comme lui il a avoué les faits en ayant
toutefois le caractère politique de la
destination des fonds
prochain non vraisemblable sur la liste
des inculpés de la faire le secrétaire
général de la chambre de commerce gérard
gautier qui avait déjà voilà plus d'un
an fait disparaître des pièces
compromettantes sur les débats de la
chambre lui préparait les réunions de
cette fameuse commission lassé des us et
est à ce titre aurait pu également
touché des pots-de-vin inconfortable
l'hommage du peuple de moscou à sakharov
des dizaines de milliers de moscovites
ont assisté aux funérailles du prix
nobel de la paix au cimetière de moscou
mikhaïl gorbatchev assister à la
cérémonie d'adieu à l'académie des
sciences et il s'est entretenu plusieurs
minutes avec elena bonner la femme de
sakharov une journée empreinte de
regrets regret d'un peuple qui avait
laissé sakharov mourir à petit feu en
exil pendant plus de six ans même
réhabilité par la suite
l'empreinte de cet exil reste est
indélébile patricia cost
l'ampleur de funérailles nationales pour
andreï sakharov aujourd'hui mais aussi
la simplicité la bousculade et l'émotion
de la foule de tous les anonymes venir
est venu dire adieu à un homme qui avait
voulu parler en leur nom et tout
naturellement des fleurs à la politique
le pas a été vite franchi plusieurs
pancartes réclamant des élections
démocratiques ont été brandis des tracts
ont été distribués des slogans criés les
échos de la lutte pour les droits de
l'homme lancé par andrei sakharov
l'accompagneront jusqu'à la tombe
un dernier baiser d'elena bonner sa
compagne des jours sombres
puis ses propres enfants à côté d'elle
ainsi que ceux d'andreï sakharov
assisteront la nuit déjà tombé à la mise
en terre sous les arbres du cimetière de
vostriakovo score à la périphérie de
moscou andreï sakharov repose auprès des
parents d'elena bonner mort en 1937
victimes des purges staliniennes
on a line de l'ess de nouvelles
manifestations à leipzig
ce soir plus de cent mille personnes ont
défilé dans le calme pour montrer leur
détermination leur volonté de changement
c'était la manifestation traditionnelle
du lundi mais les organisateurs ont tout
fait pour qu'il n'y ait pas le moindre
des au brésil résultats partiels des
élections monsieur collor de mello qui
représente la droite populiste
s'achemine semble-t-il vers une victoire
car sur les trois quart des votes
il obtiendrait plus de 52% des voix les
résultats ne sont pas définitifs ils ne
le seront que dans deux ou trois jours
ce serait en tout cas un très jeune
président de la république pour le
brésil au téléphone bernard benyamin
rappelé toutes les villes avec ses longs
sont des localités de l'intérieur qui
ont fait la différence
mais même ici et là quelques
irrégularités sans dénoncer le manque de
transport des endroits les lola
gouvernement bilan de la lutte contre la
corruption et la bureaucratie au caire
son investiture il va mettre au point
son programme de gouvernement
déjà nombreux à résoudre ce pays c'est
quoi michel rocard en israël une visite
de 24 heures pour le premier ministre il
s'agissait d'inaugurer une rue pierre
mendès-france à jaffa qui est une
banlieue de tel aviv
l'occasion pour monsieur rocard de
rappeler que pierre mas neuf ans était
convaincu de la cohabitation entre les
peuples israélien et palestinien
charles enderlin les horizons m cette
réflexion ne concerne pas les positions
politiques de monsieur chez mire mais
son état de santé
le premier ministre israélien vient en
effet d'être opéré d'une hernie
l'entretien a porté sur le dialogue euro
arabe qui doit s'ouvrir en fin de
semaine à paris
monsieur rocard a rassuré ses hôtes
cette initiative ne portera pas atteinte
aux relations entre israël et le marché
et durant son séjour le premier ministre
a pris le pouls du conflit israélo
palestinien
ce matin il a religieux au consulat de
france à jérusalem
treize responsables palestiniens
ils lui ont demandé une politique
française plus actives dans la région
nous attendons plus de la france que des
états unis nous espérons qu'elle
relancera le processus de paix des
dirigeants israéliens eux ont dit à
monsieur rocard qui ne sont pas pour une
médiation française
dans l'état actuel des jours je ne sens
pas bien comment une suggestion
médiatrice ou négociatrice de la france
puisse pourrait être bien reçu de part
et d'autre néanmoins il faut suivre le
problème tous les jours avec une immense
attention c'est ce que nous en est au
service d'une volonté de dialogue c'est
ce que j'ai dit y compris en inaugurant
la rue pierre mendès-france homme de
dialogue car c'était là le but officiel
de la visite une rue de jaffa a été
baptisée au nom de pierre mendès france
qui organisa les premières rencontres
secrètes entre des israéliens et l'ol
paie une cérémonie hautement symbolique
à laquelle assistaient aussi le maire de
tel-aviv et le ministre des affaires
étrangères tous deux du likoud la droite
lors des douze ne veut pas de la turquie
pour l'instant pas avant en 1993 a dit
la commission européenne la turquie est
en retard sur la cee at elle fait
remarquer du point de vue économique
mais aussi dans le domaine des droits de
l'homme et du respect des minorités la
cee qui a signé aujourd'hui un accord
avec l'union soviétique à bruxelles à un
accord de coopération économique et
commerciale c'est la première fois avec
lui je vais le ministre soviétique des
affaires étrangères edouard chevardnadzé
qui est venu signer l'accord
à cette occasion de leur a bien sûr de
nombreuses conversations politiques avec
les européens russell toujours avec une
réunion des ministres de l'économie et
des finances des 12 pays des discussions
serrées autour du thème de la monnaie
européenne
philippe sassier à bruxelles philippe
pierre bérégovoy re présidé le premier
conseil des ministres des finances
depuis le sommet de strasbourg mais
aussi le dernier placé sous présidence
française
quatre dossiers importants au menu
d'aujourd'hui
la réglementation européenne dopée à les
offres publiques d'achat
l'harmonisation des taux de tva et faute
d'un accord il est demandé aux états
membres de ne pas trop s'écarter des
taux moyens
le troisième dossier est peut être le
plus épineux
s'agit des contrôles fiscaux et
notamment de la levée du secret bancaire
que pourrait demander les pays européens
après le 1er juillet 1990 lorsque les
capitaux circuleront librement en europe
opposant majeurs à ce projet le
luxembourg qui a fait du secret bancaire
son fonds de commerce
enfin on a parlé de la création de la
banque européenne d'investissement pour
les pays de l'est
et puis pendant deux heures ce matin les
ministres sans leurs conseillers se sont
livrés à l'exercice 10 de surveillance
mutuelle qui consiste loin des oreilles
indiscrètes à examiner et à critiquer
les politiques économiques de chacun une
discussion qui doit permettre de
rapprocher ces politiques d'harmoniser
les décisions c'est le premier pas vers
la monnaie unique au cours de ce
véritable huis clos ministériel qui
avait rigaud a annoncé que la france
allait durcir sa politique de crédit
premiers pas ce matin avec la hausse des
taux d'intérêts de la banque de france
2e pas demain avec l'annoncé d'une
discipline plus sévères pour 1990 cela
peut signifier dans l'avenir moins de
crédits pour les entreprises comme pour
les particuliers
il faut en effet freiner la consommation
et mieux maîtriser les importations
l'assemblée nationale a adopté toute une
série de projets en seconde lecture
l'amnistié en nouvelle calédonie les
conditions d'entrée et de séjour des
immigrés en france est toujours en
seconde lecture le projet de loi de
finances pour 90 cette nuit l'assemblée
devrait adopter le projet de loi destiné
à aider les plus démunis à se loger deux
millions de ménages sont mal logés en
france et 400000 sont sans abri le
gouvernement a donc décidé de mettre en
oeuvre un plan d'ensemble de 5 milliards
de francs à base dettes personnelles au
logement de quotas l'attribution dans
les hlm et de prêts spéciaux parmi les
prioritaires les ménages modestes avec
enfants jean pesio roger mathurin se
sont rendus chez l'un de ces ménages à
montrouge dans la banlieue parisienne
moi j'aurais cherché un emploi et qu'on
me demande jambes
lise si vous habitez dans un hôtel on
vous prend pas il faut vous ayez un
logement un logement pour avoir les
mêmes chances que les autres dans la
société
voilà ce qu'offre jacqueline et ses
enfants ce trois pièces fournies par
l'association logement pour tous le
centre héberge cinq familles avec
enfants un organisme relais
départemental paye les loyers à leur
place c'est le cas des forces y est
elles étaient gardiennes à paris on les
expulse elle perd son emploi et son
logement
depuis trois ans la famille étaient
ballottées des foyers à la russie d'un
foyer au bout d'un mois on a reparlé
auquel l'organisme relais aide les
familles à obtenir de l'argent et un
emploi l'an dernier il a pu reloger 90
familles
mais comme partout en ile de france deux
demandeurs sur trois n'ont rien obtenu
au manque de hlm trop cher à construire
ou de collectivités locales il faut le
déplorer ne veulent plus de pauvres chez
eux mêmes ils préfèrent
alizée réhabilitation des rénovations de
quartier qui malheureusement en voile et
pour ouvert les vents lieu du plus
lointain logement pour tous demandent
que les organismes d'hébergement puisse
prendre en charge les immeubles anciens
et leurs occupants
impossible actuellement est bien la loi
va changer dès l'an prochain ces
organismes auront des prêts spéciaux
pour acheter ces logements en l'état un
espoir pour les gens démunis d'avoir un
toit et en centre ville à lyon
arrestation de trois trafiquants
d'oeuvres d'art dans leur voiture on a
retrouvé 14 radars en ivoire anciennes
notamment un calvaire du xviie siècle
paraît-il d'une valeur inestimable
le tgv toujours plus vite toujours plus
fort un contrat de 30 rames pour
traverser la manche et relier paris
londres et bruxelles
le contrat est signé anne consignes et
explique cela et d'autres informations
de ce lundi un contrat signé donc
aujourd'hui par les chemins de fer
français britanniques et belges et 30 kg
pays qui comme internationaux seront
construits par un consortium de deux
filles anglaises trois français et deux
britanniques prévues pour 93 londres
bruxelles en 2h40 londres paris ou trois
heures amnesty international prête à
aller au maroc
à condition de pouvoir visiter les
prisons hier le roi du maroc affirmé à
l'heure de vérité avoir invité en vain
l'organisation de défense des droits de
l'homme selon amnesty depuis 84 4
prisonniers politiques sont morts des
suites d'une grève de la faim le dernier
en date au mois d'août
six autres lundi serait aujourd'hui en
danger
joël pennel principal inculpé de la ferc
ans en kit la confrontation générale
organisée aujourd'hui à toulon par le
juge rage beau les avocats de l'ancienne
dame de compagnie de cuisine de consoles
auraient souhaité l'audition de
capelongue je déplore que l'on ne puisse
pas entendre dans ce pays un ministre
l'audition du ministre de la culture
avait été refusée en conseil des
ministres cette confrontation générale
qui réunissait quatre des sept inculpés
de la faire quand son portait sur la
cession de ce tableau de muriaux la ratp
présente aujourd'hui les 20 premiers
éléments de son groupe de protection
armé d'un bâton d'un aérosol de défense
et d'une paire de menottes
ils patrouilleront par deux dans le
métro le rer et les autobus en mars
prochain devrait être 60
les éditeurs de quotidiens parisiens
menace de ne plus imprimer le journaux
et de mettre leur personnel en chômage
technique
réponse au syndicat du livre cgt qui
bloquent par une grève depuis vendredi
les nmpp organismes distributeurs des
journaux des négociations sont
actuellement en cours
à la bourse de paris baisse de 0 19% de
l'indicé de référence cac 40 le dollar
se négocie 1 5 francs 89 50 pour
officiel dure réalité pour le tunnel
sous la manche l'eurotunnel à l'origine
le projet était évalué à 50 milliards de
francs déjà pas mal mais maintenant on
en est à 70 milliards de francs d'où des
négociations difficiles et une polémique
entre les différents partenaires
associés pour le creusement du tunnel
mais si on polémique en surface cela
n'empêche pas les travaux de continuer
en sous sol véronique auger roger
mathurin séquence exploration chaque
jour quatre mille hommes accrochent
leurs vêtements dans la salle des pendus
tout ressemble au travail de la mine
durant sa grande époque
sauf qu'ici on fore sous la mer
la moyenne d'âge est de 25 ans il y à
quelques anciens mineurs mais la plupart
des ouvriers creusent pour la première
fois
vous faisiez quoi avant d en location de
véhicules agent probatoire
vous prenez le temps protéger une sainte
barbe la patronne des artificiers veille
sur chaque tunnel motivés ils sont payés
au rendement passionnés c'est l'un des
chantiers du siècle il avance d'environ
9 mètres par jour et par tunnel dans un
an ils retrouveront les anglais au
milieu de l'un des trois voyous on a eu
des problèmes au début du chantier il ya
un an 2000 maintenant c'est parti
carole le premier tunnelier avait pris
six mois de retard au départ il les a
rattrapé la mise au point des navettes
ferroviaires a été difficile les
constructeurs renâclé à l'idée
d'élaborer des prototypes inutilisable
ailleurs finalement les navettes
couleront à 120 km/heure au lieu des 160
prévus
ce surcoût imprévu assez gonflé la
facture et grossir les frais financiers
mais en tout on s'en fiche car c'est le
royaume de tml cette association
d'entreprises de travaux publics
et comme le disent les ouvriers c'est
pas nous qui payons
au dessus chez eurotunnel on se tait et
on croise les doigts on veut croire que
dans trois ans le cimetière du village
aura retrouvé sa paix les machines
seront partis il étreint boulot conso
l'amant dans quelques minutes à 20h40
c'est la grande fête pour antenne 2 et
pour tout la télévision française c'est
la traditionnelle remise des 7 d'or
c'est au lido ça commence en ce moment
c'est un spectacle complet que vous
pourrez suivre en direct sur notre
chaîne une grande partie de la soirée
beaucoup de divertissements mais aussi
quelques récompenses et comme d'habitude
voilà quelques images du lido et comme
d'habitude je sais que je serais très
très nombreux devant leur poste pour
savoir qui sera récompensé alors à tout
à l'heure au lit double
ça swingue et en altitude c'était toute
la semaine le festival du film rock à
val d'isère sous le nom râble présidence
de l'honorable johnny hallyday le
premier prix a été remporté par un film
américain un premier film tep est d'un
film sur le tournage des clips justement
jean jacques dufour jean françois chevet
signer neige
la transaction
val d'isère a ajouté du rôle assez rock
et le président du jury jojo s'est
éclatée comme une bête dans des boeufs
d'en faire notamment en compagnie du
groupe trust 1 2 à 4 abu 3 castaing
justement le premier le gagnant de ce
festival c'est bill pullman avec tech ed
les aventures de deux garnements bien
décidé à devenir les kings du vidéo
elle vous traduisez comme en musique
vous avez dit peut-être des comptes fait
de clips à claques beaucoup de riz plein
plein de trucs plein d'idées avec un
opus vient d'être aimé réaliser avant
cela il m'a vraiment plu sieurs 3,4 qui
dit festival handi également loupé le
point sur la question
je crois que maintenant les mecs ont
laissé tomber la banane mais le perfecto
par contre on voit toujours autant en
hiver tu peux te faire quoi et c'est le
petit col pas plutôt pas parfait auxonne
1 2 bon ça un bon finisseur qui axe ses
joueurs mais qui de 3,4 l'autre en chine
qui a enflammé les festivaliers c'est
angie angie niort
vous connaissiez ce garçon qui est
chanteur mais non il y avoue cyril songe
connaissais pas je trouve formidable
il a une tronche et les coiffes au
pétard elle est géniale il invente le
rock égale mc2 une formule pour faire la
mousse sur la pierre
je trouve que c'est vraiment rock dans
l'esprit 5,6 et dernier tango d'une
semaine de nuit rock avec des extraits
du prochain film de richard gotainer
rendez vous au tas de sable ça a l'air
pas mal
la chanson est dicté le rythme si tu
veux expliquer le battement du coeur
non il y à un tir fait quinté+ demain
c'est à enghien et ça s'appelle pourtant
le prix de vincennes mais cet angle les
pronos tiré de bresse le 16 le 3 le 15
le 5 le 12 le 14 le 13 et le 18
la météo s'est tout de suite on va
retrouver laurent cabrol nominé aux sept
d'or il est des gens smoking et puis la
dernière édition ce sera vers 23h30
christian mahé mono bonne soirée et
bonne soirée avec les 7 d'or d'abord et
puis je vous retrouverai pour le journal
de 20h
bon ça